[Music]
along the border of Afghanistan and
Pakistan this is a lawless expanse of
tribal land uncovered and largely
untouched by the Afghan and Pakistani
government's bin Laden and Zawahiri have
set up new training camps here amidst a
network of thousands of trails in some
of the highest mountains on earth the
border crossing itself is rugged and
chaotic but this Pakistani military
officer insists that al Qaeda figures
cannot enter Pakistan without being
detected
there's the entry place from where
people come in to Pakistan and cross
over to Afghanistan you see along the
border we have created all those fence
and barbed wire to prevent any illegal
crossing into the country but an
American official says the border is
more porous than the Pakistanis are
willing to admit you'd have to have an
outpost every few hundred meters to be
able to observe the border people being
able to move back and forth and find
safe havens on either side of the border
is as easy as crossing the street in the
United States the US military presence
in Afghanistan has led to the conclusion
that bin Laden and his leadership are
hiding on the Pakistani side of the
border
extremist groups like the jamya ulema
Islam are openly willing to harbor
al-qaeda but good even it is an
obligation of every Muslim in every
country to protect their friend from the
enemy home to a fiercely independent and
heavily armed population even the
Pakistani military is wary of this
violent tribal region sending an army up
into these hills is not a simple mission
people who live in these regions have
been running their own affairs since
time immemorial they are proud marshal
and well resourced in part because they
have built up a rich history of
smuggling and other criminal enterprises
that have enriched them amongst the drug
runners and booming black-market for
weapons outsiders are easily identified
here in the Daraa gun market local
guides advise Westerners to stay away as
they are likely to be shot on sight
[Music]
we make weapons here pistols coalition
akov repeaters and copies of the new
weapons that are manufactured in America
and sent to us the local versions work
even better than those produced abroad
many of these weapons wind up in the
hands of al Qaeda some even cross the
border where they are used to attack US
troops there's a portable rocket grenade
launcher has been captured in an
encounter with the terrorists he'll be
deposited again with the headquarters
the best weapon you can buy it here off
in the border areas so this is what the
reality of the environment of Pakistan
is Kalashnikovs for men and the tribal
areas are like purses for women in the
United States I mean gotta have one
officially the US military is not
allowed to enter the tribal areas
without pakistani permission so america
must depend on Pakistan's troops to
conduct most ground operations against
Al Qaeda